una aparente calma frente a la sede de
los Juegos Olímpicos de París 2024
puertas adentro el comité organizador se
enfrenta a una prueba muy alejada del
ámbito deportivo en la mañana del martes
estas oficinas Fueron allanadas por la
policía financiera de la capital
francesa en el marco de dos
investigaciones preliminares por
aprobación ilegal le intereses
malversación de fondos públicos y
favoritismo en relación con los
contratos relativos a la preparación de
los Juegos Olímpicos
el comité organizador de los Juegos
Olímpicos de 2024 está cooperando con
los investigadores para facilitar sus
investigaciones
en 2017 se abrió una primera
investigación sobre una serie de
contratos adjudicados por el comité
organizador el año pasado inició una
segunda investigación sobre los
contratos entre el comité organizador y
la empresa encargada de la entrega de
las instalaciones olímpicas las oficinas
de esta compañía también fueron
registradas Este martes el director
ejecutivo de operaciones del comité
organizador eduardonelli está en el ojo
del huracán se le acusa de estar
implicado en un conflicto de intereses
cuando fue proveedor de servicios a los
Juegos Olímpicos a través de su propia
empresa a poco menos de un año de los
Juegos Olímpicos el escándalo llega como
un golpe bajo para el evento de París
2024 sobre todo porque podrían salir a
la luz otros casos el martes 10 obreros
que trabajaban sin papeles en las obras
olímpicas presentaron una demanda contra
Los Gigantes de construcción
en una investigación preliminar sobre
este caso